diese punkte bedeuten ich punkte sind
topscorer drin heißen wenn die schrift
klick auf items draufsteht muss
überleben
aloha und seien herzlich willkommen zu
einem weiteren teil des mega projekts
und dieses mal sind bei einem ganz
anderen gespann und zwar bin ich
zusammen mit luca nikkei com kraft an
ein team aloha halo effekt der kev oder
was heißt team also wir zocken einfach
zusammen im team sind wir kein bisschen
hier ist frieden wo wir uns gerade
bewegen das ist ja innerorts in der
stadt und ja also wenn ihr das kathi
vierte folglich weißen die wievielte
folge ist es bei dir glaube das ist die
sechste oder fünfte also ich hab ja
schon ein bisschen gefeilt gehabt wie
gesagt vor hin ja ich denke ich werde
nach ein paar folgen alleine auf dem
etikett endet findet ihr jetzt bei mir
täglich folgen vom mega projekt wetter
richtig durchziehen wird weil das ist
ein projekt habe ich einfach schon lange
drauf gewartet was ich noch fragen
wollte ich habe ich einfach du kennst
dich ja schon ein bisschen aus mit
gewiesen genau als dann wird erst mal
sortieren kann also job das ist ja
kupfer das ist klar
kopper ist kupfer genommen genau was ist
liter motor
aplicor ich hab zwar uhr ich hab silva
absehbar zimmer ist es nicht hin
ich glaube schon genau was du hast es
auf deutsch eingestellt alles er ist auf
englisch so dass zu sehen sind aber auch
so fast and the furious tor
keine ahnung ich leider keine das heißt
irgendwie komisch offeriert oder so aber
fast im trias ort ich dachte schon alte
dreier schwarzen schöner gesagt alles
friedlich
weil ich mich schon gefragt spiels
wirklich gerade minecraft also was auf
jeden fall machen muss also an den
inventar ist ja mit papa was dann
dann klick unten links auf options wie
geht das
was erstmal oder teppich stunden drin
hast du schon drin ja gut weil dann ja
du siehst und schwarzen balken der
schwarza das eintippen
ja genau du kannst jetzt einfach
eingeben jetpack und dann siehst du die
elektrik jackpot electric jeff beck wir
wollen einen electric jack was voll mit
energie ist selbst dann klickt einfach
drauf liest du brauchst rief ein tier in
advanced a kid red box und kloster und
aus dies heißt wir müssen in dem du
musst auf jeden fall netter und rief ein
team machte glaube ich in dem du einfach
verbremst oder irgendwie war das sonae
das muss ich jetzt noch mal anders
machen
ich habe ganze gesucht videos machen das
ist ja immer ja deswegen du kannst es
alles da schon einfach suchen das ist
mir auch nachher indizes mit sie immer
noch als relativ spät aufgefallen dass
man da was machen kann
aber das auf jeden fall eine sehr
glorreiche hilfe du siehst ja zum
beispiel ok erstmal klosters dafür
brauche ich erst mal ein netter für
netapp obsidian obsidian muss ich wasser
mit links und einfach eine höhle
gewerbler also denn dann kann man das
würde vor streit weil diamanten ja
extrem selten sind
lena hat schon neun gefunden ich habe
auch schon einige aber ich würde jetzt
nicht für eine spitzhacke verschwenden
wollen
das heißt dass wir miteinander einfach
und so ein kleines wetterportal
vielleicht brennen oder wollen wir
allgemein das wollte dich fragen dass
wir unsere grundstücke untereinander mit
zum unterirdischen tunnel verbinden
schwert des todes rubin sperren
was ist eigentlich unterschied von
rubinen smaragden und was ist das
stärkste markt glaubt auch nur zum
traden
ich meine nicht mal dass irgendwie es
gibt dafür rubin grüne grünen saphir und
das ist eigentlich genau gleich hat nur
andere farben und ich glaube dass rubin
saphir schwerter länger halten
aber da bin ich schon erich zeigt
einfach mal alle ärzte ich hab damit
dass man schießt hast du für mich ein
bisschen holz kurzen da muss nicht
wieder so weit weg laufen ja ja habe ich
moment ich schaue ich habe hier einmal
rubine krieg ist saphire genau das war
es meine und also grüne sah viele und so
viele ich zeig dir genau hier der kiste
unten
die hofer 3 also rubine uranabbau eine
menge ich hab' ich hab keine ahnung
und man kann ja ja ich wollte harry
potter zauberstäbe machen kannst du mir
zauberstäbe erwarte hier ich lege ich
dir einfach mal ganz gerne außen gebe
ich dir danke schön
ich wollte noch fragen es gibt diese
wissen durch egoistische weg es sind so
das sind die leuchtenden steine die man
ihn findet ich kann man abbauen die
glitzern so mal hast du davon
ich hab genug also von dem ein habe ich
16 von dem an 13 und eine lehrerin und
einen roten ich bin mir gerade nicht
sicher fühlt kann aus seiner sicht fuhr
ich glaube ja dass sie nicht natur aber
es gab die kannst du jedes x-beliebige
item verwandeln was du haben willst also
in obsidian blogs heißt oder so sowas
gibt es aber ich weiß nicht ob es die
wirtschafts waren dann aber aber wie man
blatter mit aussah weil ich kann das ein
zauberstab draus machen hab ich
nachgeschaut mit zauberstab ja ja einen
zauberstab und mit dem kannst du was
kann man auch mal mit dem zauberstab man
das wollen wir auch machen
damals habe ich weiß ist das ist schon
so lange her das einzige was ich bin wo
ich mich so ein bisschen auskennt hat
war aus kanada
und zwar ist das ist einfach nur gummi
also aber ist halt das was ich da mache
die jugend auf englisch aber nicht immer
ist jedenfalls gummi einfach und uni
braucht man um
bestimmte dinge sagen wir mal zu
energien aktivieren deaktivieren und
zwar wenn ich habe 2000 stäbe und die
laden energie auf etwas kannst du das
machen verlauf wand auf ich habe einmal
ein bluttest einmal eindrücken auf mich
drauf mit 60 oder so ich jetzt tot
schlag mich noch immer bisher wurden 50
aufgeladen wie kann ich dir einsetzen so
hoch mache ich überhaupt ein grundstück
das irgendwie zitiert dass ich will
zaubern
hokuspokus hokuspokus jetzt auch keine
zaubersprüche es gibt ja ja ja ich will
aber zaubern
ich verstehe das nicht sie habe sich
aufgeladen bis 50 energie vielleicht mit
lade taste ich gehe noch mal kurz ein
bisschen holz holen also mit kopper gibt
es halt so da raus musste die alte oper
cable machen wenn du zum beispiel
generator hass und einen mails rater
dann kannst du damit zum körper cable
miteinander verbinden aber da muss ich
auch nochmal rein fressen in die
kompletten dass ich auch immer bei nacht
einfach losgehen muss
hast du wohl oder irgendwie sowas leider
nicht ich wollte könnte man einfach wenn
du zwei leute auf den servern könnte man
dann einfach nur pennen menschen eine
ahnung was da kann auch nix anderes aus
diesen zauberstäben machen
verrückt ich weil ich kenne ich jetzt
auch nicht so gut mit vize beats aus ich
weiß halt nur was ist das herzlich jetzt
die einfachen ja erst kam
zu einem ja zu mir hin bringt aber fast
gar nichts er kann ja mit involve
wittern und wolf ich habe noch irgendwo
meiner oder des days auf frei gemein
gelände
ja aber ich glaube das ist meine also
ich könnte dir gehört mir schon oder
nein wir dann ja dann hätte der ein
bändchen glaube ich hab's lang grün gilt
mia geilo also ich muss wirklich wissen
was mit dem zauberstab machen kann ich
kannst du ja einfach da ich hab leider
keine zwei bildschirme parallelen das
blöd weil hier geht das hier ja aber was
kreativ du kriegst auch ein zauberstab
neben der austin green zauberstab und
ich hab nämlich ein elf zaubert starb
und ein feiner zollstock gemacht
ich denke ich feiere man ja gut ich bin
hier gerade in unserem komischen dorf
geladen sie gerade witches hat huber
nein ich hab das kann ich jetzt jetzt
jetzt gehe ich durch
ich hab keine ahnung sind das hier
einfach aus landschaften die von den
greens malt hinzugefügt wurden also wo
ich hier gerade für den coco da muss man
doch zaubern können die für mich
was passiert ich gehe auch so ein dings
und sagte hey ya die wurden vom alter
das war laut ich glaube jetzt habe ich
wenn irgendeiner bronze geschlafen hat
ihn hätte ich aufgeregt wieso kann ich
es gibt verschiedene wann was also die
heißen ihre fähigkeit haben wir
eigentlich den server hier auf normal
leben rund aber feiern mit all diesen
schwimmendes frei ich kann das nicht
anklicken dass es so komisch besonders
ins feuer werfen oder wie wenig ich muss
noch mal wirklich jede taste mal durch
drücken das ist
du kannst ja auch einfach so ein
komisches bienen zeugs dingsbums ich
will auch wissen wie man die tabelle
hinten stehen komische liebsten dichter
alter diesen gaildorf wenn ich die sowie
dahin pflanzen könnte dann wirklich
überall im garten sitzen boxen sniper
das bräuchte nicht wegschmeißen nicht
gut
das gar nicht so ich geh jetz auch
glaube ich der direkt zurück ich wollte
einfach mal diese geilen sie kann nicht
der in diesem fall schön die machen so
mit so eine richtig ich glaube ich mache
mir ein haus wo ich überall so
verschiedene ich packte also
verschiedene welten rein also da mach
ich da so ein bisschen schnee hin dann
macht das ein bisschen wüste hin unseres
alles halt verschiedene sachen drauf ich
bin ja ich weiß gar nicht was ist denn
überhaupt riss das ist irgendwie sowas
wie im stärke oder keine notiz wenn ihr
einen sog einlassen sonst also ich kenne
mich jetzt auch nicht so gut aus mit
fiete wies allerdings diese start sind
nicht sehr selten gibt schon ein
bisschen öfter hoch ist also man kann es
irgendwie soll man angeblich also ich
habe geguckt jetzt hier da gibt es ich
habe jetzt einen schlechtesten den
zauberstab und dem verbessert dann wird
er irgendwann so richtig guten
zauberstäbe also so frost und was weiß
nicht was ich muss eben nicht ist mal
wieder zurückkommen ich glaube ich
schaue erst mal schnell nach uns geht es
nicht eine sekunde
also bei mir mal kurz einen kleinen pfad
aber sage ich so live bei dir ja das
geht ja gar nicht wissen sucht hier die
ganze zeit
das reit im winkl so kann ich den guten
machen
bitte bitte bitte ist es das was denke
dass denke nächstes plane ich finde
einfach mal eine pyramide okay ich weiß
ich weiß aber wie ich jetzt hin
das weiß auch immer jetzt wie ich den
verbesserten machen kann
mir fehlt aber dazu der gelbe chart ich
gehe gleich definitiv zurück in die
stadt weil ich habe ein bisschen angst
die menschen vermissen
irgendwie war das so wie ich das gesehen
habe das heißt du brauchst verschiedene
charts in den zauberstab zu machen und
was kann dieser zauberstab dann keine
ahnung verbesserten nachhelfen
ich weiß es wirklich nicht ich glaube
das ist der standard vielleicht geht es
auch so wasser sich ein artig
hab ich schon standard zauberstab fertig
aber noch nie schlagen weiß ich was
diese punkte bedeuten ich punkte sind
ein mops bonner darin heißen wenn die
schrift klick auf items draufhält sie
war sehr groß überleben was wenn es
schifft klick auf die teams darauf weist
auch diese ja das sind wände die
verbrennens glaube ich kriegs energie
raus mit den maschinen mit mitstreitern
so was alles weil sie nicht du brauchst
mich eigentlich gar nicht fragen kämpfen
voll wenig lena dachte auch schon sehr
echt dass die welt vorliegt also simon
weiß noch ein bisschen was und sonst
endlich erkennen
das ding ist ich will wissen wie ich die
verdammten zauberstab mal aber wir sind
ja auch nicht hier um jetzt hier krass
alles zu wissen sondern mit den jungen
zu unterhalten und ihr wenn wir alle
schon wissen wer auch langweilig das
heißt wir müssen dass der raps auf ein
bisschen aneignen das heißt ihr könnt
auch einfach in die kommentare schreiben
wenn ihr irgendwelche tipps ab wenn ihr
wisst was ist mit seinem zauberstab
anfangen kann etc
dann könnte es einmal bei cap schreiben
oder halt auch bei mir weil da machen
auch so ein ding und zu verzaubern
terroristen gelaufen ich bin jetzt
gerade wieder auf meinem grundstück ja
irgendwie laufen irgendeine ruine oder
bisschen erkunden
ich brauche erstmal rüstungen alles
nicht machen das ist meine kiste das
wäre für mich erste priorität weil ich
laufe hier mal in die richtung vor ihnen
ich habe mir jetzt hier so eine rubin
spitzhacke macht irgendwie 20 rubine
gefunden und stand bei jemandem zu
verschwenden ich mache das weil ich mich
kurz beschützen
musik gibt normal machen
ja was ist wichtiger fakt reaper eltern
die ganzen creeper gehen einfach die
ganze zeit darauf dass regeln richtig
auf das richtig mobil ist offensichtlich
nicht stärker als eisen mein komplettes
grundstück wird es also die bienen ist
nicht stärker als eisen das kann ich dir
sagen ich brauche creeper drei schläge
genau wie bei reisen
das regal geht ja klar also ich klage
jetzt erst mal ganz kurz meine ganzen
sachen hier ich brauche auf jeden fall
definitiv noch ein bisschen eisen habe
ich noch alten ich hab keine ahnung wie
cook ist danach gibt man ihr bis 1 unten
vielleicht kann ich da irgendwas nach
liest wie eine leise gebiet na ganz
einfach die eingehen oder die anreise
nicht also bald wieder damit so gut
gespielt haben gab es einen king von den
bienen und es gab einen natürlichen ich
dachte gar nicht wenn ich sehe immer nur
diese bienenstöcke und wenn ich die
abbauen will nie kaputt so ich glaube
jetzt hier irgendwelche ruin weil hier
habe ich immer das gefühl dass man schön
was findet ich habe das gefühl
simon hat eine große ansprache gehalten
von vegf omega schrank gefunden
von wegen er würde ich jeden tag was auf
jeden fall hochladen und direkt am
anfang aufnehmen
nach zwei folgen wollte weg vom fenster